Let's go over now how we can actually solve the top K problem using this idea of partitioning.
Now, remember what we're given her is the list L and some number K
and what we're interested in are the top K elements of L,
and for the sake of simplicity in this example by top--I mean the smallest,
the one that have the smallest values.
You can always put things around, turn the right greater ends into less ends
and so forth and everything will be fixed,
but for now, let's just imagine that we're interested in the smallest element--
the smallest K elements if the lists were sorted.
Here's what we're going to do.
We're going to start off--remember we know how to do a partitioning is giving some v,
well I don't know which value to use, so let's just pick one at random.
Here I am picking a value at random--let's say there.
There's our value v, and now, we're going to run the partitioning algorithm on this,
and there is a couple of different cases that can happen.
We're going to look first at this case 2 because that's the super duper easy one.
In this case 2, we pick some v at random
and it just so happens that we totally locked out and the rank of v is exactly K.
What happens when we run partitioning on that value v
is it's going to separate all the values of L into the ones smaller than v, equal to v, and greater than v,
and that happens to be position K,
so the ones on the first K positioned here are exactly the top K for the list,
the smallest K elements that we were looking for.
In this case, we're done--we locked out.
But that's only one of the three cases. We need to look at the other cases now.